what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about all minds impending death
or rather I will be talking about the
fact that sir Knight ice quark foresight
predicted that all might would die a
gruesome death at the hands of a villain
and this is said to happen sometime in
the very near future just to be clear
all might is not dead into my hero
academia story and so in this video I
will be focusing on certain ideas
prediction and whether there is any
chance for all my to escape the dark
fate that sir Knight I predicted the
answer may surprise you so definitely
stay tuned before we dive into it I want
to give a massive thank you to
crunchyroll for sponsoring this video
crunchyroll is the world's largest
destination for anime and manga and I've
been a paying customer for over three
years I use crunchyroll on a daily basis
to watch my favorite anime series like
black clover attack on Titan Demon
Slayer and many more this season I am
obviously watching season four of my
hero academia which is being simulcast
on crunchyroll along with dr. stone fire
force and other hit anime series
crunchyroll also has a manga section and
that's where I go to read the latest
chapters of the seven deadly sins attack
on Titan and so on go to crunchyroll.com
slash anime uproar to get crunchyroll
premium free for 14 days you will get
unlimited access to their anime manga
and drama titles ad-free
in 1080p HD and that includes the newest
anime episodes with professional
subtitles check it out for yourself try
out crunchyroll ad free for 14 days
right now by signing up at
crunchyroll.com slash anime uproar or
just click that link in the description
that way you get great anime and manga
content you help support the anime
industry and you help support this
channel at the same time it's a win win
win just sign up at crunchyroll.com
slash anime uproar or click that link in
the description heads up even though sir
tonight eyes prediction about all mites
death has already been revealed in the
enemy so it is not a spoiler
for anime only fans in this video I will
be drawing on some material from the
manga that has not yet been covered in
the anime if you don't want to know any
information beyond the anime please
proceed with caution you have been
warned as soon as we first meet all
might in chapter 1 of the manga and
episode 1 of the anime there is some
pretty clear foreboding about all meit's
health and physical condition in his
true form his small might form if you
will all might real name Toshi nori yagi
looks extremely frail and emaciated he
also has massive scars on the left side
of his body and he has shown spitting up
blood so we the readers and viewers are
being told right off the bat that all
mites health is fading and that he is
not in a good physical condition when we
see this our first instinct is to think
that there is something seriously wrong
with all myself
and that he may not be around for too
much longer
so from dec whose words declaring that
this is the story of how he became the
greatest hero to the fact that all might
is clearly well past his prime it
wouldn't be a stretch to assume that at
some point all might could potentially
die and Deku would then carry on all
mites legend as the next greatest hero
we later learned that all might severe
injuries are the result of an epic
battle that he fought against the arch
villain all for one and even though all
might won that battle he still suffered
lasting injuries this includes serious
injuries to his stomach and respiratory
tract injuries that would be completely
debilitating for a normal person and
injuries that are not going to just heal
over time at least not completely not
long after that battle all mites then
sidekicks sir Knight I was worried about
all might all might was severely injured
but he still refused to retire and he
decided to keep risking his life on a
daily basis in spite of his injuries so
sir Knight I used his quark force sight
to look into all mites future and what
he saw rattled him sir Knight I foresaw
that 6 or 7 years into the future all
might will
a horrible end at the hands of an
unspecified villain it will be a death
so terrible that it is too gruesome for
sir Knight I to even describe it since
all the predictions made by sir Knight
ice clerk had always come to pass
eventually sir Knight I became convinced
that all mites recklessness would
eventually lead to his death at the
hands of a villain it has already been
about 6 years since that prediction was
made and if the prediction can be
trusted that all might could be killed
literally any day now so is it really
possible that all might the legendary
hero and inspiration to so many could be
killed off in the boku no hero story
would Kohei horikoshi really do
something as drastic as that to be
honest I think it's definitely possible
all might has always been portrayed as
Pretty Reckless
he often rushes into dangerous
situations without any regard for his
own safety because he prioritizes saving
other people to keeping himself safe all
might considers it his responsibility as
a hero to help as many people as
possible and he is more than willing to
put himself in danger in order to save
someone else because of that it isn't
too hard to imagine a scenario in which
Almighty puts his own life at risk in
order to protect someone from a villain
and since all might is much weaker now
than he used to be back in his prime
taking such risks could eventually cost
him his life almighty ro ik death at the
hands of a villain most likely there
Shigeru key or maybe Dobby would be
heartbreaking for all the heroes and all
the heroes students but it would also be
a major motivator for them if all might
were to be killed by a villain Deku
would be devastated but eventually dekha
would come to see all my tragic death as
additional motivation to get even
stronger and become an even greater hero
Deku would be determined to prevent such
tragedies from ever happening again and
he would work even harder than ever
before if all might were to die it
certainly wouldn't be the first time
that we see a legendary mentor character
die only to
his death inspired the main character to
reach even greater heights after a
period of grieving and self searching of
course my favorite anime of all time is
Tengen Toppa Gurren Lagann so I
definitely know a thing or two about
this type of scenario therefore I would
say that it is definitely possible that
all might might eventually die and that
this tragedy would then transform Deku
into a more mature protagonist I don't
necessarily want this to happen I kind
of want to see all might hook up with
deck whose mom to be honest but hey
that's just me and if you're thinking oh
but deck who has a dad he's just
traveling for work I don't know about
you but deck whose dad sounds like the
type of guy who would tell his wife and
child that he was going out to the store
to get some milk and then never come
back maybe I'm wrong but at this point
we know more about togas dad than we
know about deck whose dad which is
saying a lot with that said it is still
possible that all might will not die in
the boku no hero story sir nite ize
prediction certainly suggests that he
will but the epic finale of the eight
precepts arc gave us an important clue
about sir nite ize quirk and its
limitations during the final showdown
between overhaul and Deku sir night I
squirt foresaw that Deku would be killed
by overhaul however we know that this
did not happen instead thanks to the
help of Ares quark rewind deck who was
able to defeat overhaul and survive this
was the first time that sir Knight I
realized that his quirks predictions of
the future were not absolute in certain
rare instances the future can be changed
so can this same logic be applied to all
Minds death can the future be changed so
that all might doesn't actually die
perhaps but the problem is that we're
not exactly sure why Deku was able to
change the future it's possible that he
somehow did it just through the sheer
power of his will but it could also be
that the real secret ingredient to
change in the future was actually arrey
arrey squark is directly related to time
she is able to rewind the bodies of
others to a previous state it is
possible that Ares repeated rewinding of
Dec whose body during the fight against
overhaul messed with the time and
altered the timeline itself
so without arey Dec who would have died
but because ares quirk rewound dec whose
body it also changed the flow of time
and changed dec whose destiny in the
process if this is the case that all
mites death cannot be avoided unless he
learns to control her quirk very soon
she is still learning to control it and
until she gains better control of her
quirk she is just as likely to hurt
someone as she is to help them but if
arey is the one who has to intervene in
order to change all mites tragic fate
then we have to remember that all might
could die any day now the prediction was
that he would die in six to seven years
and it has already been over six years
since the prediction was made
if arey is the key to saving all might
then area will need to have a major
training arc very soon otherwise all
might will be in serious danger
especially now that the villains are
getting stronger and stronger by the day
Shigure Aki squirt in particular has
evolved to such an extent that the idea
of him actually killing all might is not
nearly as far-fetched as it would have
been at the beginning of the story so
will almighty really die or will he be
saved and hopefully hook up with deck
was mom with the way that the story has
been going especially in terms of the
evolution of the hero society and the
rise of the villains and the Liberation
Front
if all might were to be killed by say
shigaraki this act would be extremely
powerful and extremely symbolic from a
narrative perspective it would signal
that the old era is gone and that a new
era full of chaos and uncertainty is
here to stay all mites death would
profoundly change all the important
characters in the story including of
course Deku and it would be extremely
interesting to see how the story would
develop after something as drastic as
the death of all might the legendary
symbol of peace that said with decos
defeat of overhaul
all horikoshi definitely left opened the
possibility that all might could also
change the future and survive possibly
with the help of Ares quark this
scenario in which all Mike doesn't die
would also be cool with me and if he
survives then it will be possible for
him to make sweet sweet love to Dec
whose mom so that would also be a win in
my book but let me know what you guys
think is all the foreshadowing and
foreboding about all mites death going
to lead to his violent end which would
lead to the beginning of a dark new era
in the story or we'll all might change
his fate and stay alive beyond the seven
years that sir nite ize quirk specified
hit me up down in the comments and feel
free to include your own reasons for why
you think that one option or the other
is more likely if you enjoyed this video
you want to see more boku no hero
content and right here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
please don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest boku no hero news and
updates finally don't forget to check
out our sponsor crunchyroll just click
that link in the description for a
14-day free trial as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]